happy exercise or sexual arousal can  lead to excess moisture in your upper  thighs and crotch now you can remove the  wetness immediately with the Stephen  Miller vaginal dryness life just open  the locker and imagine White House  adviser Stephen Miller the architect of  some of the Trump administration's  harshest policies making eyes at you  trying to seduce me  but the locket does more than dry vagina  when I dropped my phone in the sink I  thought I'd ruined it but then I put the  wet phone between my legs and opened my  Stephen Miller locket just gazing into  his dead eyes dried up everything down  there including my phone the Stephen  Miller vaginal dryness locket is so  powerful rescue teams have started using  it to combat flooding in coastal  communities  [Music]  [Applause]  the Steven Miller vaginal dryness locket  finally doing some good  [Applause]